he's obsessed with the interaction of
permaculture and data science and he's
working on a device to automatically
weigh and count chicken eggs
so please welcome Mitchell hello
everyone I'm Mitchell I do some data
science Consulting I predict the future
for people with my company necktrick and
I'm going to talk about the software
that I've created for R called Fable if
you do any time series analysis you may
have heard of this before but if you
haven't done much recently you may be
more familiar with Rob's package the
forecast Library
so I'm going to start with a bit of a
history Rob was supposed to give this
talk but unfortunately couldn't make it
so he was going to talk about 30 plus
years of his experience in open source
now I don't have 30 plus years of being
alive so I'm going to give a condensed
version
starting in the turn of the century we
have the TS package which was brought
over from s into R and this brought with
it many useful and fun time series
functions including TS arima and
everyone's favorite filter function
now Rob came onto the scene creating the
forecast package published in 2003 and
he extended he built on the work of the
TS package with tier subjects to add the
ETS forecasting Library forecasting
method and theater forecasting method
and since has developed more methods
which are used today in industry
many years later I worked on it in 2015
and essentially you'll see shortly that
I tried to fix a bunch of the design
problems make it a bit more tidy
compatible with the Tidy verse but
pretty quickly we realized that it
wasn't going to work this way
so Eero is also working on the time
series stuff at the time and she created
TS tibbles so sybils is bringing time
series to tibbles which allows us to use
tidy verse hands up if you're using the
Tidy verse
most of you wonderful hands up if you've
made an r package or are making an r
package a few less so I think this talk
will be particularly useful if you're
thinking about our packages but it's
also nice to think about the design of
packages as well
so I started working on the Fable
package in 2018 which is the natural
successor to the forecast package much
in the same way that forecast built on
TS the Fable package has built on Sybil
so that we can produce forecasts that
are compatible with the interface of the
Tidy verse
and shortly after the forecast package
has been retired it's no longer with us
we are still maintaining it however
we're not adding any new features so if
you are using the forecast package I
hope this talk is a bit of a convincing
story for why you might consider moving
to Fable
so if you've made an r package before
you may be familiar with many helpful
packages for making our packages
some of these are here so you might use
use this to get started oxygen to
document your package test that to add
your unit tests and so on and maybe next
we'll talk here from Jared about how lab
large language models can build packages
as well
but there aren't as many tools for
Designing our packages
maybe large language models can help
with this too but there's not really any
one answer for how to create or design a
package sure you can design a package
that passes tests that is well
documented but what makes it easy to use
and learn
so the Tidy verse does have some design
guidelines that are published but good
design is subjective and is critically
important for the adoption and
functionality of your package
the principles proposed by the Tidy
verse is that it should be human
centered
meaning that we're designing for humans
your errors and your hints should be
very helpful and human readable
it should be composable we all love how
you split the D player chain into
various parts and you can change the
order to get different results so
composability is splitting it up into
building blocks to solve the problem
it should be consistent I hope this is
self-explanatory but if you do the same
thing in two different ways and you get
very different results that could be
very surprising
and inclusivity is important as well and
a big part of inclusivity is solved by
addressing the previous principles
making it easy to learn good
documentation makes it very accessible
so the design of the forecast package is
different from the Fable package in a
few ways but the design of both packages
are good for their purpose so what were
the goals in that we're solving with the
forecast package and the Fable package
the forecast package developed much
longer ago was solving individual time
series forecasting often you're focusing
on some GDP figure or maybe income and
you just have a single time series
that's only observed every quarter or
year and it's not such a difficult
problem to forecast
now modern daytime series we collect
large collections of Time series often
very frequently you might have 30 minute
electricity demand or you might have
event data like every time someone hires
a city bike
that's a much more difficult problem to
represent and the time series class the
TS objects that the forecast package
Builds on are just not suitable for this
so the forecast package focuses on
single regular and infrequent
observations whereas Fable can work with
any time observation
when producing some forecasts it's
interesting to see uh the nature of the
forecast that you produce the forecast
package initially focused on just making
a point prediction what exactly did we
expect to happen next into the future
and then shortly after it added
intervals indicating some sort of
uncertainty
the Fable package goes one step further
and we'll see why this is incredibly
helpful it actually gives you an entire
distribution for what might happen next
and there's various benefits that you
can compute from a distribution rather
than just intervals
and lastly forecast is designed around
the TS objects whereas Fable Builds on
Sybil so that it's compatible and
interoperable with the Tidy verse
so I'm going to talk about some design
elements on each of these packages some
mutual components if you will and how
they differ between forecast and Fable
and hopefully offer you some tips for
why I've made these design decisions for
statistical software and the tips that
you might like to apply when designing
or thinking and working with packages
so I'm going to tell this story with
trips to Australia
and here I've simplified it a little bit
but essentially we have four main
reasons for why people come to Australia
you can come for business you can come
for a holiday you can visit your friends
and family or maybe there's some other
reason
and every quarter we count the number of
people that have come to Australia for
this purpose
this is a common time series structure
if you've ever loaded in a Time series
data set a CSV or from a database you
may see your time variable the quarter
variable here is represented with a date
you have this zero one you always use
the first day of the month for some
reason when representing quarters or
months but that's not very precise
to represent this data with forecast you
will need to convert it into a TS object
and TS objects on their own are a bit
limited because they can only work with
one time series but we have four
so to start I'm just summarizing the
total number of trips regardless of the
purpose
and because TS is built on vectors
rather than data frames I have to pull
out that Trip's variable so I get the
vector that column and then I need to
re-specify what the time variable was
even though I had it in my quarter
column I cannot use it and there's a lot
of other extensions for Ts that try to
build and improve up on this but TS
which is forecast bass requires you to
start all over again when describing
your time structure
a very important part of your time
series
now you also need domain specific
languages to work with TS objects if you
wanted to slice and dice in time we use
the window function so I'm going to
start from 2012 comma 2. in this case
it's referring to Quarter Two but if I
had monthly data this would be February
the second number here too
so a bit confusing multiple loadings of
the same interface
now if I wanted to represent all of
these four time series there is a class
for this MTS multivariate time series
and it's a wide format and if anyone's
familiar with the Tidy verse wide
formats are sin we like our long format
and there's a few reasons for this to
get the TS subject we convert it to a
matrix and then a TS object but this is
all trips data what if I had something
else what if I had the amount of money
that they brought to the country
then I would have business count
business money business something else
there's a lot of other variables that
will get something really wide that's
hard to work with
so the TS format is very efficient and
very minimal and for the purposes of the
podcast package just forecasting single
time series it's a great choice
but in the modern day it's not holding
up
it doesn't work with multiple time
series you need domain specific
languages and if you're familiar with
the Tidy verse you need to learn a whole
nother way of filtering time
and it needs to be regular
the Fable package on the other hand
building on Sybil is allowing you to
work with something that looks very
familiar a tibble
but instead we act a bit more precise
instead of having that zero one first
day of the month representation of
quarter we have special classes for this
year quarter so it's a precise
representation of quarters and other
than that it looks and behaves exactly
like a table you can use ggplot you can
filter mutate all of your familiar verbs
we add some extra information the first
row here one Q represents that we have
quarterly data and this was
automatically inferred from the quarter
column we didn't need to tell
anything about the nature of the time
now to filter to slice and dice we can
use familiar verbs if you all use filter
before I hope that's very natural and so
when it comes to using or designing a
package
it's much easier to learn a package if
you already know half of the language if
you already know the Tidy verse it's not
that much more to add as Sybil you can
still use filter to slice and dice
so as opposed to the TS format the Civil
format has a lot of Pros it fixes a lot
of the issues that the TS object has
with just one con it takes a little bit
more space
we're using a data frame here instead of
just a sequence of numbers
so a tip a takeaway from this is to
design The Familiar functions if your
users are familiar with the Tidy verse
design around the Tidy verse if your
users are familiar with TS objects
design around TS objects
what about modeling in r
so the forecast package has ETS one of
the first functions added and this acts
very similarly to Stats of Rima or
tsarima when it was first added and if
you have not seen time series modeling
before essentially we pipe in out here
subject at the first argument and then
there might be a whole dozen of
different arguments controlling the
parameters and different ways you can
model this
and you get a model object out here out
of this
can anyone guess what Lambda represents
in this model
it's very domain specific if you're
unfamiliar with forecast or time series
you would have no idea so another tip
from this is to design with terms that
are self-explanatory don't be afraid to
write long text that describes in detail
what you're trying to do
Lambda is actually saying do a log
transformation
now there are other models that forecast
provides tslm and this uses a different
interface entirely if you've used the LM
function the formula interface it looks
very familiar but going between them
they have a very different structure
now a different type of model or more
accurately a method in forecast doesn't
give you a model at all it just directly
gives you a forecast and this can be
very surprising you think of seasonal
naive as a model but suddenly you Skip
One Step and you get forecast and this
inconsistency can make it really hard to
work with this software
I'll skip this for time
as opposed to Fable we force all of
these models to have a consistent
interface and we've chosen to go with
the formula interface because this is
what regression cross-sectional analysis
would be familiar with
and in addition we've split up this step
of taking your data and modeling it into
two components two building blocks that
allows us to work with it in more
situations
with the first building block is the
specification of the model
ETS tslm and seasonal naive the second
building block is model applying our
model specification to some data and
fitting the model
now the slide that I skipped is where
it's really useful in Fable we can use
these building blocks as inputs to other
functions or inputs to other steps and
because these are all functions it's
very extensible anyone can write their
own STL function and put it in the model
function it's very extensible where
forecasts lacked
so some key differences between forecast
and Fable for modeling Fable has a
consistent interface the formula
interface
it separates specification from fitting
a model and it allows any combination by
doing this separation you can apply
models of models in very flexible ways
so think about designing consistent
interfaces built up of very small
components very small building blocks to
get a more flexible General approach
the third of four elements that I'd like
to think about is accuracy
the accuracy approach in forecast
designed around a single forecast or a
single model at a time is quite good you
pipe it into accuracy and you get a set
of accuracy results
these are the familiar ones that
forecasters like to look at but they're
not all of the ones that you might like
to consider and there's no ability to
change what you get here
if you wanted to compute the accuracy
for a different model you do the step
again and again
but a common task for forecasters is to
see I've got three models which is my
best model and to compare this you need
to do three calls to accuracy
for fable because we have all of the
objects in a single model class we just
pipe it singly into accuracy and then we
return a very familiar data structure a
tibble
we all know how to work with data frames
and if you've got large collections of
models or time series you can use ggplot
you can summarize reduce this in any way
you like in order to better understand
which model is performing better
you can also specify your own accuracy
measures so it's extensible maybe you're
working for a company and they have a
specific kpi that they're interested in
and my software is not going to include
that kpi for you but you can create your
own functions and use them directly with
the accuracy in order to compute this
kpi
now so far I've shown you a single
accuracy measure for the total number of
people coming to Australia but it's so
simple much like tidy bursts if you just
remove one of the steps you can get a
different result these are the building
blocks that I was talking about so if I
remove this aggregation step if I now
consider all of the reasons why someone
might come to Australia
I get a separate model for all of the
reasons they come to Australia and a
separate accuracy measure so maybe we're
more accurate at predicting holiday
demand than business demand maybe one
model is better than others for
different types of coming to Australia
maybe I wanted to see overall across all
of these four reasons for coming to
Australia which model performed the best
I can use D player no new no new tools
needed
so a couple tips from this some key
differences the Fable package makes it a
lot easier to compare across different
models and across different time series
you can use the skills that you already
have with the Tidy bus
it also supports custom functions for
accuracy metrics so if you have a
specific kpi or a specific scoring rule
that you like to use you can bring that
with you
so the tip that I'd like to give you for
this element is to design extensible
components not just for other packages
to make extensions like ggplot
extensions that we all love but also
users try to design a simple extension
approaches that users can build upon
the final element that I'd like to
consider is forecasts the forecast
package creates this custom forecast
class it looks like a data frame but
it's a list it's a bit deceiving in that
way and it provides Point forecasts and
intervals
if you wanted to change the intervals
that you get you need to run the whole
forecast again
not great
to extract the elements from this
forecast you need to know what this
internal list structure looks like so we
might extract the mean with FC dollar
Min the forecast object means element
the upper bounds in a matrix and the
lower bounds in a matrix
however this forecast meme contained in
dollar main is that actually the mean of
the distribution
well in this case it's actually not and
this is where design can get really
challenging especially when you're
building a long a package over a long
period of time things change we added
Transformations and suddenly the mean
that is contained in this object is
actually the median if you know your
statistical Theory and to actually get
the mean you need to set bias adjust and
this bias adj it's not very descriptive
for what you're doing what
so if I add biased adjust I get the
actual means
hopefully we can do better than this for
fable
so in Fable I'm applying the same
modeling across many different time
series those four and you can see on the
left hand side of my formula I'm
specifying log instead of Lambda very
natural
I can also mix Transformations I'm doing
log plus 1 here and when I forecast not
do not just the mean distribution that I
get in the main column I get a trips
column which is an entire distribution
and you can see that this is a
transformed normal
and sure enough this mean is actually
the mean of the distribution
now with a tabular format the data frame
we can mutate we can manipulate our
distribution so if you'd like to extract
the median you can call median of the
distribution if you'd like to get the
intervals you can compute the intervals
of that distribution you don't need to
recompute the forecasts you just compute
on that distribution
so there's many other functions that you
might like to use you can extract the
CDF the quantiles high low highest
density regions there's all sorts of
tools available and this is in the
distributional package
so there's some key differences with
forecast it produces distributions not
intervals it gives you a data frame so
you can use the Tidy bus and it avoids
confusing terms like biased adjust when
you see mean it means the mean
so describe use simple and descriptive
terms don't try and Shrink like bias adj
spell it out and also provide outputs
that are ready to use when you predict
from a linear model you might get the
mean and the standard deviation you
can't directly use that you need to use
our Norm or D norm and so on the
distributions are ready to use
so in summary we have the tidyverse
design principles and some tips to
achieve these is to build upon familiar
functions if your users are using a tidy
verse utilize that skill that will help
them get a head start on learning how to
use your software
also consider to be internally meaning
consistent within forecasting methods or
modeling so you always get the same
model class and externally so that
you're consistent with other packages
that you might work with
use building blocks to break the problem
apart and have simple descriptive names
so thanks for your time try forecasting
with Fable if you haven't it's easy by
Design and chat to me anytime I'd love
to talk about our forecasting and
chickens thank you
[Applause]